joining us now with more freedom caucus
chairman andy biggs he's supporting an
amendment to remove
congresswoman omar from her committee
assignments also joining us the author
of the new book they never let a
crisis go to waste fox news contributor
jason chavis
author of the bestseller firebrand
florida congressman matt gates who
today earlier today offered to resign
his place in congress to help the
president fight impeachment if indeed
needed
the people of pensacola in the panhandle
need matt gates
i'm not loving this president has good
lawyers and david shone
um all right let me first go this to me
andy biggs is simple
it's up to the voters in omar's district
and
ocasio-cortez's district and greens
district
uh they should decide these things
apparently they knew a lot
about all of these candidates prior to
the election
why isn't the same treatment why didn't
that go to the conspiracy theorists
the the people that have nutty views on
the left
well you're exactly right sean all of
this was a
in the wash it was baked in in the votes
so if you're going to
take marjorie taylor green offer
committee then you need to be looking at
all the conspiracy theorists all the
hard left rhetoric that's come out
all the violent rhetoric that's come out
how about sleeping with the enemy
and being on intel how about spreading
false hoaxes and rumors
all of that should basically foreclose
those people if that's the
standard but this is a this is a
historic thing because
they wanted the whole body to come in
well they know they control it
to start removing republicans and i'll
tell you marjorie taylor green if this
happens will just be
the start they will go after a couple
other people then it'll be somebody else
and it will always move the goal post
because they don't want
opposition loud strong people and don't
forget marger taylor's a strong
conservative voice for for women
and they don't want that either all
right matt gates let's get your take on
all this i
i trust the people in your district that
if they want to elect you
they know they're getting a fire brand
end of sentence they get to decide
uh people get to decide on maxine waters
and
nancy pelosi and ocasio-cortez uh
you know how is this double standard the
whole impeachment lie
conspiracy adam shifts his constituents
get to vote for that pathological liar
that's right marjorie green said some
crazy conspiracy things before she was
elected to congress
adam schiff eric swalwell jerry nataler
and most of the democrats
said crazy conspiracy theory things when
they were in congress
impeaching president trump and
attempting to
delegitimize his time in office as a
consequence of the russia hoax
marjorie taylor green got 75 percent of
the vote
that's more than the votes more than you
almost
that's more than almost every member of
congress so it is a dangerous precedent
when we disrespect the voters and that's
really what the left is trying to do
they're saying the people of america
don't matter it's the decision-making
process
inside the beltway so tonight the
republicans decided to keep
liz cheney tomorrow the democrats will
boot
marjorie taylor green from her
committees i think both decisions
reinforce the power of washington and it
only encourages me to try to go out in
america
and get people focused on the changes we
need to make in both parties so that the
voters are respected i laid out the
hannity conservative agenda that's what
i focus on
limited government more freedom low
taxes less bureaucracy controlled
borders i went through the whole thing
uh congressman chaffetz let's bring you
in on all this it's the same
double standard though with how we
define insurrection language right
because donald trump said
many of you will peacefully
patriotically march to the capitol so
your voices will be heard
well uh chuck schumer was threatening
two supreme court justices
joe biden threatened the president
kamala harris
was bailing out rioters and saying they
shouldn't stop
doing what they're doing uh and maxine
waters
said she wants to take the president out
and kill him tonight i'm going to take
him out tonight isn't that a direct
threat
sounds like it to me
yeah it was a direct threat and the
democrats conveniently forget about al c
hastings alcy hastings was appointed by
president carter to be a federal judge
guess what he was brought before the
house of representatives he was
impeached
and then he was convicted in the united
states senate but you know what the
people in florida decided to send it
back to congress
the guy was convicted of bribery and the
democrats put him on the rules committee
of
of all things and yet you've got
somebody who said something that
i totally disagree with before an
election but you know who gets to make
that decision
the good people of georgia not the
opposing party not the democrats
and not somebody from utah or arizona or
anywhere else
the people of georgia that's where the
respect needs to lie
i think that's true all right andy biggs
where does this go tomorrow
and more importantly you know at what
point do we start
applying the same standard all we're
all i'm asking for is equal application
of the standards
equal application of the laws you know
due process under the law
we don't seem to have any of that in
this country today
that's right tomorrow if it goes like i
think it's going to go the democrats
have the votes
they'll probably remove marjorie taylor
green that's why i co-sponsored that
that amendment where we substitute ilhan
omar for marjorie taylor green because
we're trying to get one for one if
you're going to take out one of ours
we're going to take out one of yours
but we're still in the minority but
we've got to get the majority back
uh in order to be able to to apply this
but i tell you what we have got to
we have to keep talking about this
because it is so disparate this
this treatment here and what nancy
pelosi has done to try to
irrigate power to the center that is a
huge problem and this is just one more
step in that
matt what's going to happen again
tomorrow they are going to take the
unprecedented action of substituting the
will of washington
for the will of people in this country
and when we get the majority back
we better apply the same standards so
often i see the democrats
actually fight to win and republicans
are playing some patty cake game
i certainly hope that's not the case
that we point out the hypocrisy and the
double standard because it is eating
away
at our voters and the country and jason
you've said it publicly he's told me
privately it's one of the reasons that
you know you got
fed up with congress
i i did you know republicans when they
get into power they try to be democratic
light they go easy
they don't play offense now what the
democrats are doing is beyond
offense that this is just offensive and
it is a dangerous dangerous precedent
but republicans have got to remember
that when they have these the the power
and they have the votes they got that's
when you have to make their move and
stop being democratic light for goodness
sake
make the case win the argument on the
floor that's why matt gates and
biggs and others jim jordan are so
valuable we got to win the
communications war
all right guys thank you all appreciate
it